[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
are you Breakers your roomies out there
this is our daily show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news that you
need to know coming up today is
Daredevil The New Wand
also we're going to be talking tons
about phase five so much to talk about
there and finally we have Tommy's
diagnosis stick around uh later on the
episode for all that before we can find
out what's wrong with Tommy let's
introduce our guests today hey we got
Erica joining us once again
uh hello Internet and hello to Whitney
van laningham
I'm so excited oh we're so excited to
have you back on yeah we pulled you away
from your desk forced you to be on the
break room I'm sorry everyone I do have
to leave uh fairly fairly soon I'm Gonna
Love You So Hard till I do that's Joel
is gonna say while I'm still here let's
have the best ghosting time together
you stay in chat she'll never leave I'll
never leave yeah we also have Tommy back
to it yeah I don't want to tease this
diagnosis segment too much but let's
just say it's internal and it's bleeding
a lot oh my goodness well he does got a
a lot of animal parts in there if you're
a true breaker and you know the lore
behind Tommy's body it's barely his own
anymore he's our our regular ship of
Theseus over here Tommy's body is my
favorite summertime Blockbuster
I go down to the club and I tell the DJ
put on Tommy's body you know I want to
dance that's actually my favorite
episode of Invader Zim you know yeah the
more organs make you more human and then
he eats all the eats all the organs I'm
an old man somebody Invaders have
knowledge is very low very low but if
you want to talk centurions I'm here for
you all right if anyone wants to talk
gold black and white sitcoms I'm here to
talk about The Patty Duke Show the life
of Dobby Gillis and perhaps Leave it to
Beaver rest in peace Wally I thought he
was alive nope he's dead again
he evaded me for 24 hours but I slit his
throat
we can have you arrested before
Comic-Con which is happening tomorrow
less than 24 hours tonight you don't
want to oversleep stay awake for 24
hours uh join us here for Comic-Con
tomorrow G fuel get your Jeep Fjord use
our affiliate link if we still have one
hey we're doing a Redemption today and
it's permanent okay for every 100 we
raise in super chats today uh in honor
of Jessica who's not here today we're
not doing face painting but we'll be
tattooing ourselves that's right we got
a whole bucket of tattoos bucket of
tattoos permanent tattoos yeah uh at a
hundred dollars whoever wants to do one
will do one and then we'll go for from
there 200 we'll do two more yeah at 300
we'll do three more yeah you might think
these are very trendy uh and awesome
tattoos that will have no problem
putting on your body and that's right
there's a whole mix in here here's a
blind one for you uh this is pretty good
this is an Aquaman that's a zap oh if we
get to 800 I'll put one on my face and I
won't take it off till tomorrow we got
some we got some frozen in here some
JoJo siwa you could I could really go on
like I said you guys have a really good
opportunity here because I have to go to
a very important meeting after this you
could [ __ ] up my whole face if you
wanted to yeah yeah you really could
yeah how much do you guys want how much
you guys wanted do you want me to go to
a meeting with Aquaman on my face I will
oh yeah well for you but only for you
guys I got I got reprimanded uh by HR
for going to a meeting with Aquaman yeah
well you should have used the towel I
should have used the towel hey we're
also on the Tic Tac folks uh the break
room is now on Tick Tock at the
underscore break room Tommy has been
getting into the mind of a young social
influencer and really taking over our
Tic Tacs really really reaching out with
those Trends grabbing you by your uh
your social anxiety and shaking you
until you uh follow us and we demand
that you follow his name is trusted and
he likes to serve and now I have
capacity of his brain like when Dr
Octopus took control of Spider-Man's
brain I'm controlling trust in now and
our talks are
are lit they're fired
we're mad sauce they're slapped they're
cute they're chewy and they know how to
Boogie hey you know what Tommy bet yeah
hey what about some headlines say less
it's like beautiful beautiful headlines
Spider-Man freshman year producer Brad
vinderbaum provided some details on just
what we can expect from the series he
said quote it follows the pattern that
you see in Civil War down to Peter
getting the broken Blu-ray player from
the trash and he walks into his
apartment for the famous moment where he
meets Tony Stark and he's waiting for
him he offers the stock internship they
take him to Berlin but because of things
that happen in the Multiverse because of
new random occurrences it's not Tony
Stark who's waiting for him there it's
Norman Osborne and he owns Norman money
and Norman stabs him no I'm just joking
it's Norman Osborne and that sends his
life in an unexpected trajectory that
collides with him uh and meeting many
unexpected characters in the Marvel
Universe uh this sounds like a ton of
fun yeah I love the artwork that we saw
for it that kind of classic uh Marvel
cartoon look from the 60s yeah yeah I
really like it and more Norman Osborne
please yeah with his waves on swim I
can't wait yeah
it's going to be great we're going to
see lots of cosplays next year of the
new Norman Osborne hey Miss Marvel head
writer bisha K Ali addresses time travel
in Miss Marvel in a recent interview she
was asked if she broke abmcc MCU time
travel rules and she wasn't having that
uh she answered uh that she did she said
yes we had the Avengers end game that
you can't go back like a consequential
thing like this is something like smart
Hulk was explaining how time travel
worked you can't just go back and change
things but she said however between
endgame uh and that another little show
came through called Loki and she said I
think that it wouldn't have caused the
Nexus event because of the inevitability
of it so it was a closed loop
um she's basically saying like yes we
broke the time travel rules they
established in game but Loki kind of
introduced a whole new set of time
travel rules I think that's fine that's
fair it's also we're going by what Bruce
Banner says and he's the smart guy I'm
not going to Discount him but he doesn't
really know time travel that well he's
he's theorizing a lot
so there's probably different he's one
of those packs that says science stuff
and you just don't really got to listen
to him
okay you gotta trust your gut about time
travel and other things don't listen to
yourself
do your own research when it comes to
the time do your own research make your
own opinion
there's some great videos on YouTube
about time travel all you gotta do is
watch half of one of those
when you're tinkering with the DeLorean
you just feel it out list of monkey
wrenches you know time travel is more
about Vibes yeah like honestly if you
could get through the ice wall that
surrounds our Flat Earth yeah then
you're able to access the time the time
yes it's a Time River so you don't
believe we're in a dome oh we're in the
Dome on the back of three Turtles that's
right yes we're in a pleasure though
pleasure Dome on the backs of three
Turtles but basically if you've got
problems with how time travel works in
the show they thought about it they did
look they're ready for you come at them
come at them next headline Kevin feige
is promising some big swings from
Deadpool three oh boy he said and I got
another quote for you guys how do we
elevate it in the way we've been able to
with Civil War Infinity war and Ragnarok
which were all the third uh movies I
know those are random three movies like
what the hell is he talking uh he goes
on to say that quote it's very fun to be
in the Ryan Reynolds show uh that sounds
like a lot of shade thrown at Ryan
Reynolds good job Kevin yeah Civil War
and Ragnarok were both team up movies
you know you got Tony and Captain Hulk
do you think they're gonna pair Deadpool
with someone already in the MCU that
would be fun what if what if he has to
go to hell and get Scarlet Witch out
yeah
she's down there with Doom's mom just
hanging out yeah Doom's mom I think it
would be fun to pair him with someone
and now I also like pair him with the
most serious person in the MCU which is
kind of tough there's not a ton of
serious people left Vision in the MCU
yeah
[Laughter]
they go So Meta that Ryan Reynolds quits
I don't want to do this if no one's
laughing at me I can't work with this
guy although they did pair him up with
cable and Deadpool too yeah which was
great like a superstar so what if they
paired him up with like someone extra
goofy already in the MCU man or somebody
yeah it's too bad like Thanos is dead
because it would be great to have him
with Josh Brolin again
variant Thanos
the head Thanos or Josh Brolin did demos
and what if right he came back
in half it was great bring it back he
loves it he loves it he loves me and
Thanos yeah he loves being Thanos as we
all would whatever what a great guy
gotta respect him hey next headline in
an interview with Josh Horowitz Taryn
egerton clarified his meeting with
Marvel was not to play Wolverine get off
it bub uh he said he mentioned it he
said he mentioned the character in that
meeting but Wolverine was not the one
who's he going to be I mean we think
they're going to bring the Edgerton into
the MCU is this like a real meeting
I don't know no the thing about it is a
little inside baseball oh boy here we go
big celebrity you know how well I I you
know I I know
he's a big popular TV and film actors
all the time where they discuss
characters they give them a ton of comic
books because they're they're like
formulating like what if where do you
fit in how interested are you going to
be in because one thing that the Marvel
Studios seemed to like are people that
are they buy into the character like
they read the books and they're like I
connect with that so I mean this could
have just been like Taryn come to Marvel
Studios we're going to give you our
offices we're going to give you a a long
box of comics send you on your way sing
us a little else in tune and little chin
get the F out chin yeah I don't know I'm
just saying don't read too much into it
Taryn might not be playing anything
maybe he's maybe he's gonna be a PA on
the next movie oh yeah
you start somewhere
that's right I don't know I think he's
lying through his teeth yeah because
we've been lied to before a lot Andrew
Garfield said he had nothing to do with
no way home and then it popped up and
it's super prominent lying about having
a role is literally called garfielding
now oh that's what I call it that was my
head I thought you meant the lasagna
first yeah
well also why not also the cat yeah why
not both that's right
yes Garfield
perfect get it done would be like a good
Gambit yeah I think
he's got it yeah
I hope they I hope they do cast the
X-Men and it's a bunch of 20-somethings
and then they let Channing Tatum come in
as an ultimate for no reason why but
they still met him play like a 20 year
old yeah yeah
[Laughter]
hit some hard times he's dancing with
the boys
all the tips and set them on fire
he bites some buttons off a lady's shirt
and lights them up and makes them crack
up
watching this movie
Just combine the two that's what I'm
saying right there this is the back door
pilot for Magic Mike five that's what
I'm saying I love it I love it some
people in the chat saying the thing for
Taran at good times
[Music]
that would be awesome my boy morph morph
should be in the Deadpool movie oh I
would like that yeah he could be whoever
he went that way Deadpool Deadpool can
make it many characters yeah it's like
the way homelander makes that guy dress
up like Elizabeth Shoe and uh the boys
admits to having a burner Reddit account
wow she was on uh Seth Meyer's show and
she said she Anonymous anonymously will
fight with Marvel fans so a true hero
out there doing her Duty in the trenches
trenches she said she says she has
multiple accounts uh and it's very
liberating for her I mean we know lots
of people have their fake twitters right
they like to get in there mix it up in
the comments yeah it's also I think it's
a little unfair to go on like the Marvel
subreddits and argue about what's going
to happen on the show
I think that's great though because dude
that means that like anything could be
anything could be from onion could be
actually true so that uh that is just to
say believe everything you read on yeah
every single again yeah if it's on the
internet
believe it uh Iman we know you love the
channel we know you're probably in the
chat right now
you're out there throw a clock emoji
yeah yeah yeah we also ran a few posts
today uh we asked about bisha's
explanation did it make sense to you 69
of you said yes 69 very nice very nice
uh and also do you think Deadpool 3 will
be better than the previous now that
it's in the MCU 71 of you saying yes I
mean we always want a movie to be better
than the last one yeah let's do it let's
I think they'll have a lot of fun now
that they can really have fun in the MCU
yeah uh one more headline here Dwight
Johnson revealed uh cryptically
cryptically how Black Adam will change
the DC eu's future he said in an
interview with Screen Rant quote uh but
also he wanted to create a movie that
would start the pendulum swing in the DC
Universe in addition to the a hierarchy
of power that I've been talking about
this pendulum swing will usher in a new
era of the DC Universe a new anti-hero
era a new era of tone and a new era of
story it's gonna get even darker in the
dceu
didn't we just have a show called
Peacemaker on HBO Max
raspberry peacemaking I mean that was
entirely following uh
yeah Suicide Squad all anti-oh
anti-heroes Dwayne needs to sit down and
take a fight I don't know if he's
watching all the movies yeah if the
Rock's not in it and he's in almost
everything yeah it doesn't exist it's
true I think he won I think he's caught
up on the DCU but he probably watches
while he's working out yeah
attention that's true he's so yeah he's
such an unbelievably hard worker he
probably does read like comic books on
the treadmill or something
I don't know what the shift of tone
yeah
our dark anti-heroes I I really like
Shazam and like it's style and I've
Loved kind of the The Suicide Squad look
of things like adding a little levity to
this dark dark property of gods yeah
yeah dark Gods so I I don't know
more brooding
[Applause]
brooding guys we're not even close to
getting attacked
at all you don't even want to ruin my
life like a little bit uh we did we have
gotten a couple super chats Tony Kevin
uh sending in a Super Chat saying
Jubilee shows up in the MCU for the
first time what's your reaction oh baby
I'm flipping over every chair in that
movie theater a while now I'm going
crazy I'm clapping into the movie I
think we should go down the line yeah I
will freak out big until the movie ends
here's my reaction I'm flipping out huh
I love dazzler oh how dare you the
slander
I did that just to anger Brandon I'm
sitting next to Brandon as he's clapping
for the rest of the whole movie and I
decide to film it for posterity you're a
true friend I will light sparklers in
honorable that's not legal to do inside
of a movie theater
yeah yeah yeah well don't allow it just
for Jubilee screens
I lied earlier I got one more headline
for you Fantastic Four will not be an
origin story yeah
but he said quote a lot of people know
this origin story a lot of people know
the basics how do we take that and bring
something that they've never seen before
uh end quote uh producer dad posed the
question do we think we'll see them in
their origin another phase five title
like do you think they'll do Origins
later like just introduce them and then
we'll we'll kind of flash back I think I
really think people just get it I get to
like the Fantastic Four having stayed
out of
um
out of the Affairs of the like Avengers
conflicts in the past wouldn't make a
lot of sense but it would be kind of
cool if they cast the 616 uh Fantastic
Four as like men and women in their 50s
like people want like Keanu like if Kia
someone said Keanu for Johnny Storm like
Reed Richards is like Brian Cranston or
something
just like the old ass fantastic like
they've just been already doing it
they're like yeah we had other stuff to
do we were trapped in an
interdimensional war or like they just
do stuff but they're not flashy about it
like we don't go out on the street they
don't they get rid of the costumes right
a cute little jet with the open air
that's right yeah yeah
uh and then it's just like yeah we've
been doing stuff but we're not trying
yeah we don't need lunch boxes yeah yeah
uh and then the thing says I hate being
made of rock he says that every movie
guys they'll never stop saying it that's
his main quote our main discussion today
uh is showrunner Jessica GAO of She-Hulk
saying Daredevil will have a significant
role in She-Hulk I think we were all
shocked when that footage came out of
the most recent trailer he just rolls
right into frame you know yeah so we
have like this we have like this big 18
episode Daredevil Born Again coming up
yes we've got Daredevil in the uh
Spider-Man freshman year yes we've got
Daredevil and echoey here yes so much
Daredevil there's a lot of devils and
they sure are daring to do it and just
like that we are across the tattoo
threshold you want to get matching tasks
oh my God yes well just some tats while
we're talking to me matching texts all
right yeah I'm bringing them over I'm
bringing them over all right you gotta
go don't [ __ ] in don't let go I'm gonna
pick from my heart yeah okay this one
what'd you get
[Applause]
I will get
some up
uh what's his name Sven from Frozen
[Music]
all right here you go here we go sorry
you guys can keep talking yeah so
where's the most painful place we could
get these uh permanently just like I
mean like right I guess whoever you're
most sensitive oh you don't want to rub
themselves first
I'm going to take the plastic off very
importantly yeah you're right here we
take the plastic off getting a tattoo
yeah
the showrunner of She-Hulk though she
did say bang you know she didn't think
like in a million years they'd be
allowed to use Daredevil so this
probably wasn't like the original pitch
for the show and they might have like
pitched the idea as they're like writing
the show we don't know when at what
point they're allowed to use it but they
they did hear when they were like
putting the show together that Charlie
Cox was coming back and so they were
basically like can we use them if this
stuff is bad yeah and they're like yeah
sure go ahead
[Applause]
uh low key can Daredevil be in the show
uh so we know that like Jennifer Walters
She-Hulk oh yeah oh that's a beautiful
one yeah
Inked Up Baby
like the technology the technology is
there it's come a long way 200 I'll put
two more on my belly yeah
DJ crew oh this is so sick well thank
you for helping me get my very first uh
tattoo just in time for my meeting yeah
enjoy your tattoo all right so they have
they have a history in the comics of
Jennifer Walters and Matt Murdock like
working together they're both lawyers
the same lawyer bar they drink the same
lawyer drinks they build their own
objection they both yell objection uh
where do we think they're gonna the
meeting is gonna happen here we see them
like meeting on the rooftop him in
Daredevil form but you think they're
gonna cross past lawyer wise oh I think
that makes the most sense right yeah I
feel like maybe maybe She-Hulk is able
to figure that out like she's like oh
that's you're you're the you're the
devil yeah did she smell better can she
just be like oh it smells like him oh
does does Hulk Hulk does Hulk give you
better smell I haven't seen it as a
power but that makes sense super strong
nose he never says it but you I think he
whispers Hulk smell yeah
all right I think so I think they meet
in court first I think that'll be the
first meeting uh whether or not it's
over Abomination is yet to be seen but
she definitely meets Abomination or sees
and talks to him in that lock chamber
yeah all right let's talk about
abomination this is the kind of the idea
we were pitching in the thumbnail here
is that like it seems like Jennifer
Walters is going to be representing
Abomination do we think it's the other
way around oh is she is she able as like
she's the prosecutor and she's gonna
prosecute Abomination oh does she get to
go meet him and still interview him but
maybe Matt Murdock is going to be his
lawyer and represent him and it's going
to be kind of a Twist she's not actually
representing Abomination she's
Prosecuting and does that mean that
Murdoch and Titania are working together
possibly unbeknownst maybe John you got
a theory or you're just coming in I'm
coming in
coming in hi I got a pajamas who's
getting taped I don't I don't have a
theory I don't have a theory all right
moving along
yeah I I think it would be a fun little
twist if it's actually like Matt Murdock
in charge of Defending yeah Abomination
absolutely because that's what I still
don't understand about what they're
setting up here like it you know the
Superhuman Division if she's part of the
doj I don't I guess she could be
provided well the dodc and the doj like
working together because if she's a
lawyer she would she would be working
for the Department of Justice not
necessarily for the doc unless they get
set up with their own law division which
seems insane this is so fun
again but we did see in the trailer like
there's hats with with the symbol on it
that looks like the Department of
Justice symbol in our world you're gonna
get to edit if we oh yeah you want to
tap while we're talking no no no no no
we got it we still got a raise we're
halfway to another one don't worry it'll
get there and people want to trust the
process 200 means two tattoos
uh uh but let's
let's Daredevil like further out right
right we have this big series coming
um called born again which is like a
very interesting title because they've
done they did one of the seasons maybe
the last season of uh the Netflix
Daredevil was based off of a coward book
and I'm gonna get this wrong series I
think that was like called rebirth or
something yeah right yeah it had a very
similar type of title as born again uh
so it's like is this going to be like a
whole new
thing I wonder if sorry no go for it you
took it a deep breath I was just ready
to go go ahead fire it out of the
chamber uh Charlie Cox in an interview
during this sort of no way home time
period was like it's the same Daredevil
but a different story and we're not
picking up from where we left off in
Daredevil season three and The Defender
Series so I mean Born Again feels like
it's a little too on the nose to be like
a softer reboot title right
um
yeah it is it is super literal
um I don't I don't know it's it's really
weird but but I do think that the
character is gonna get a soft reboot I
don't see how you don't have a soft read
book well because he has a different uh
uh he has a different costume now which
you know it doesn't necessarily mean
like Electro still had the same
storyline in no way home but he had a
different costume so that's not a
perfect signifier of what's gonna happen
but I have to to think that fans of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe who have not
seen the Daredevil show of which maybe
the Venn diagram is not uh as separated
as I may be thinking it is
um are not gonna they're not gonna be
like you have to watch three seasons of
television in order to like hang out
yeah I agree with that I think that's I
think they're gonna they're gonna a lot
this is gonna be an inclusive Daredevil
come on in you haven't you have to watch
the Netflix show but if you have we'll
wink at you yeah
all of this is to say with all of this
Daredevil why this is so much Daredevil
now so much have you seen Charlie Cox
it's a hot man I mean he is a hot man
it's not just like Charlie Cox's
animated versions like they're really
pushing Daredevil if they wanted him
this bad for so long I have a feeling
this is a payoff of something that
they've been trying to do and now they
got them and they're like
also like we don't know I mean I mean
the the showrunner of Shield said he's
heavily involved right he might not be
an echo a ton right like there's a
chance he's an echo for an episode yeah
right he goes on the roof and he goes
oops wrong roof see you in another show
for 18 minutes
18 episodes it's three times as long as
the other Series yeah uh I I don't know
you know like
it from reading the interview it seems
like they were the ones pushing for
Daredevil to be in She-Hulk they were
interested in this character rather than
Kevin feige saying like you have hey we
have the rights to Daredevil now for
Netflix like we would love to use it
more and more though at the same time
right like uh we don't have we don't
really have a lot of Jeremy Renner
anymore in the MCU after Hawkeye we
don't have the rights to Spider-Man we
do need some of these street level
people and uh Daredevil has fans already
um it seems like a really good fit yeah
I'm not owning Spider-Man outright uh
and and feige this we kind of
emphasizing we have the three tiers of
Heroes street level right you know
Avengers level and then like Cosmic
Spider-Man's everyone's favorite street
level even though he's all three yeah uh
he's the favorite street level like hero
they don't have him now they have
Daredevil and Daredevil is everything
that Spider-Man's not when it comes to
VFX right yeah Daredevil does not shoot
anything right you need a guy who can do
some flips he's gonna get some glasses
he hops on some rooftop that's easy
that's not swinging through buildings
yeah it's not shooting web that's not
doing artistic uh acrobat stuff in the
air much easier to have a daredevil on a
TV show than Spider-Man on a TV show
yeah like much much less work do you
think we'll get She-Hulk in Daredevil
born again or do you think that this
will stop they'll sort of do HBO some
people got to be showing up right
Jessica Jones would get Luke Cage I
think they might split it up and do like
a Nine and Nine oh sort of like what
Star Wars
like you have two chunks of
um
once they do nine they take like eight
months off and they do another night I
disagree but I I like that I think it's
a straight burn all 18 drop in one night
like Network show those are sort of
doing that yeah 23 episodes 24 episodes
like no one on streaming is doing 18. oh
it's pretty rare but I you know what
maybe that maybe this is they're like
Daredevil is popular enough we can try a
little something I think I think they're
trolling us and they're gonna be five
minute shorts could you imagine if they
like rebranded as like Daredevil
Chronicles and it's just like or yeah
you said procedurals this might be the
Daredevil show because they're getting
18 episodes it might be like a law in
order so every episode is a new a case
the streets are defended by two equal
but important entities the lawyers who
try the cases
[Laughter]
he's really trying his best to work
through the legal system it just gets
fed up at the end of every episode it
beats people ah screws like throws a
stick at someone knocks them out started
doing paperwork when you're blind yeah
do paperwork where you're buying it
don't forget we have that uh Super Chat
Redemption right now we're so close to
two hundred dollars and we'll get
something I'll do mine I'll do one of my
head yeah
I'll put one on my face you don't do it
on your face John you've got court
tonight uh you're represented by Matt
Murdock
super Chatters out there uh uh Brian
Rush sending out a Super Chat is there a
dark hole in every universe is there if
there's a jar called in every universe
is there a book of Ashanti and
everything oh it was the one that was
destroyed 838's book if they killed the
a38 for Shanti well no there was just
one at the junction right that's that's
a really interesting question they had
already gotten the book of Ashanti
that's how he defeated Thanos in A380
right so that they're they didn't put it
back I imagine maybe they put it
um I don't know so that Universe might
have had its own but they did go from
838 to the maybe it's like the library
and there's they got many editions you
can check yeah sure uh uh free girl
sending in a Super Chat why is Chris
Evans head on the X-Men video game just
because it is that's a good little
Easter egg
I was so confused by that I was like is
there a new game coming out I thought we
missed a piece of news
that was fun yeah John that's your job
speaking of passing on the blame taking
accountability is very difficult and
some of us are trying to do that that's
why we want to thank our friends it
better help for sponsoring the break
room this week multiple folks on the NR
staff have used better help in the past
and guess what your boy is currently
using it we're big fans of taking care
of your mental well-being now me it's a
long road ahead they gave me a 15-year
membership because they said we're gonna
have to UNF this one little synapse at a
time now a few Folks at this General
unions helped set up better help
accounts for their family members that
have never tried online therapy before
or need a little encouragement and I
extend that to my brother Rob let's fix
you okay that's a really great way to
help someone you love invest in
themselves better help online therapy
will assess your needs that can match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist in less than 48 hours I'm
living proof baby I signed up online
answered a few questions then like 12
hours later a very nice woman emailed me
that was a separate thing for a dating
site that I was on then a couple hours
after that better help got at me and now
I'm all set up like I said I have an
appointment I have a plastic thing and
if you don't believe me if you say that
guy may not be reliable just check out
all the testimonials they have on their
website of real users sharing their
experience with Better Health therapists
and this is the part that warms my heart
they have a special offer for our
Breakers our roomies you little tiny
trash bags get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com break room that's 10
off your first month of online therapy
at better
h-e-l-p.com slash break a rule people in
the chat are calling me out for being
wrong about them getting the book of
Ashanti they said they use the dark hole
to defeat Thanos that's wrong right they
did get the book of Vashon yeah he was
also into the dark hole he was using the
Dark Horse the dream walk but then he
got the book of Ashanti I gotta watch it
again someone pull up my
use the dark hole to make delicious
pizza Papa I think he did wow I think he
definitely all right that's all you need
to know that's all the pizza's so good
he's never just kneading dough just like
that he's gonna get a super chat from
the storm Virgil saying do you smell
that it smells like mandatory fun in the
end oh
I didn't wear deodorant today that might
be what it is yeah yeah that could be
what it is
it's time for mandatory fun
so fun we play the graphic till it's
done hit it again
until it's done the segment
so full of promise we played the full
trailer for blondes trying Anna day
armist yeah just kidding we're not gonna
do that
but we don't have NC-17 fun on this
year attractive I feel feelings for her
I want to reach out if anyone knows that
Anna if you're listening actually I do
have a phone number oh great that
doesn't make I don't believe that oh
yeah
right now and I turn an even deeper
shade of red now Daredevil fevers sweep
in the nation and there's no cure but
for every Kingpin or Bullseye I don't
know why that got me right it's all
about timing baby the devil of Hell's
Kitchen faces some pretty crappy foes
for every Bullseye or Kingpin So today
we're gonna pick d-list Daredevil foes
to cut a wrestling style promo against
good old Matt Murdock the winner of
course will be decided by our brilliant
attractive chat so who would like to cut
their first promo bait you're going to
do it in character as the villain I'll
I'll go first okay uh she blocked my
number oh okay she has every right too
my villain is uh the jester baby
uh but Marvel has the gesture okay his
name is Jonathan Powers uh what a name
what a good name that's a great name he
was a struggling actor okay he was
trying his best okay
you've got the role of Cyrano de
Bergerac actually yes he got the wrong
but he was fired after one performance
oh my God because it was so bad this
drove him insane he kept he he worked on
all the things that made you a good
actor right yeah like his quads and caps
well he took him out of gymnastics
classes he took uh bodybuilding fencing
so he had all the skills uh just bad
actor no one believed him in in the role
uh so he he hooked up with the tinkerer
to have him build like uh the Tinker
build little props for him so like
innocent little traps were actually very
deadly traps he was all practical joker
I'm the jester baby uh and they're gonna
bring him back for for episode 16 of
Daredevil born again uh which we know
what will be a procedural now oh yeah
and he's gonna see Matt Murdoch and he's
gonna be like oh Matt Murdoch you think
you're so clever well I have a better
one for you I will put you into the
darkest places and pug out your eyes
like so many crows of Hell spawn Satan
they're my arrest
search
new Marvel villain oh yeah I loved Gore
wait till they meet the Jets Halloween
time this is gonna be fine I can see
tons of kids dressing like that he's got
a yo-yo look at that I mean that alone
makes him a great villain
that's his line I like that yeah well my
character uh let me just get into it
real quick get into it deep breath oh
[Applause]
this Ric Flair
oh hi above the barn it says hi Leland
owlsby aka the owl the wisest of all the
Barnyard creatures I can turn my head a
full 320 degrees around and I hunt
nocturnally and guess what when I eat I
recently learned I digest everything but
the bones and feathers and fur and then
I puke it back up yeah nothing comes out
my back end only at the front yeah and
guess who else is coming out the front
Matt Murdock AKA Daredevil I'm gonna
grind your bones to make my bread
I may have been an accountant before and
gotten a little bit of trouble with the
IRS but I'm Gonna Make You d i e this
Saturday and wrestle first
yeah well I think in real life to a lot
of children and wives
some women on that airplane I love that
he's also got like Wolverine yeah
yeah he's a fan sometimes he has but he
also ends up he's a mutant uh he gets
mutated in some versions of the comics
you know we all know owls are famous for
their quads yeah yeah I believe so
talents you know uh thank you for giving
me camera too give me camera four for a
second
hang on the screamer
um uh David anger here AKA anger the
screamer a radical social activists and
uh that's right Daredevil you've got
nothing on me you'll get your powers for
just being blind why why did you hit
radicals
they're always radicals I don't want to
hear any more from you
it's right there
I I understand this experimental uh
experiments to give me away
superhuman Powers I don't need food and
drink I can manipulate sound
with my screaming yeah awesome
um I wasn't prepared for this session
I thought Whitney was gonna be in my
chair yeah come spend the day with me in
the ring no food no water only my voice
and your precious little ears and I'll
show you who's the real superhero wow
thank God that was bone chilling
this is what it is
handling that I'll tell you what that
voice matches yeah
amazing they had anger on Agents of
Shield that's how you know his equality
oh my God they put him on ages that's
amazing all right Eric all right back to
follow here we go coming this weekend we
gotta say baby we got spilled man
all these platform shoes where you can
stretch your legs and hop over there
devil yeah baby my only Power is my my
real name is Wilbur day
that's an addendum
call me Mr Dave cause I'm all up in the
sky baby stepping over this is that
second Race Street level of superheroes
like Daredevil and kicking them with my
platform legs look at this right here
yeah I got a metal suit
Daredevil's got metal batons we gonna be
clinging like some iron steel drums when
we get the testimony we got wrestlefest
this weekend catch me step man in case
you forgot my ridiculous man oh man
toe-to-toe with the devil of Hell's
Kitchen baby all right oh my God it just
gets tall ladies and gentlemen well
those are the 4D list uh uh Daredevil
villains yeah vote in the vote in the
chat now well while you guys are voting
we'll go through a couple more Super
chats here yes zest 13 sitting at his
super chat now that Eric interviewed
Amman uh new rockstars is MCU Cannon
agree we are already FCU for sure I
think so we're pretty close because we
are DC EU Eric Eric was on uh Good
Morning America which foreign
[Music]
yeah we're definitely I think we're full
Cannon now yeah for sure for sure and we
own cannons and we'll fire them at our
enemies
uh Gabriel that doesn't Senator super
Chad the dceu tone shift is from
terrible to okay at best
[Laughter]
everyone
okay okay
Super Chat what if we get Daredevil and
midnight Suns uh I hope we can turn up
on midnight says I would love the irony
of them doing midnight sons and no
Daredevils yeah cause he's in everything
else he's a little Overexposed with you
guys uh John John the screamer it looks
like you're coming in I was losing to
Eric for a minute well do you think he
just has his legs cut off and then this
is just extra no he's got his legs still
yeah it says telescoping metal legs
that's almost like I'm just saying like
we didn't need to go back to this but he
like chopped off his leg so again
we also ran a poll who will be the
better lawyer Matt Murdoch or Jennifer
Walters 65 percent of you said Matt
Murdock we haven't seen Jennifer in
court yet it's not fair it's not fair oh
so Matt lost a lot of his cases an
absolute
barn burner of a poll but in the end I'm
afraid Eric did win but one percentage
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is
uh all right 30 more dollars and we
tattoo ourselves again I don't know if
that's worth it for any of you jabroni's
out there but
is happening tomorrow whether I gotta
take over the Mainframe by myself or not
I will hack in yeah do it unless the MCU
drops uh pulls a Beyonce and drops uh
the Christmas special tomorrow yeah yeah
if they do like a secret Captain America
movie then I guess we have to cover them
I'd say we skip it
by the way if you're wondering where
Jessica is I saw some of you in the chat
earlier she's hard at work making
costumes for all of us yeah yeah her
fingers are bleeding yes that's the
dedication yeah most definitely uh well
let's talk more about phase five
gentlemen how about that uh we have so
many other things that are happening in
Phase five though we haven't even like
barely scratched yeah the surface yet uh
like coven of chaos Thunderbolts this
fourth Captain America movie that John
is admitted he hates
what what
a lot of these things do we think that
we're going to see white Vision again in
one of these phase five properties are
they just holding them up does he go
it's like a wild card yeah you see the
Captain Marvel that they'll bring back
when they need to bring it back yes I
just
I don't know I feel like the longer they
leave a map the more we forget he exists
and the more like when he comes back
we're like all right
you know like it's not like Captain
Marvel where you're like oh this is a
character we're excited to be joining
the MCU we already have Vision now we
have white Vision yeah they're basically
after their their little circle speech
where they flew around inside that
building they're the same character now
again right like he's basically got old
Visions memories now right yes but he
has no Humanity right he's just a
machine and machines learn and they get
sharper and they get better at their
tasks but I think like white vision
would be a perfect candidate for this
Thunderbolt snow oh yeah that's
interesting because if you put the right
words in that idiot's brain he'll do
whatever you say that's true I think it
makes sense yeah I was thinking dodc's
connection with white Vision I know that
we don't know when armor Wars is
happening but if at all it is happening
the showrunner said it was happening you
said no guys really
um I think um I promise Kevin said so
um I think uh with the dodc creating
white vision and I imagine the dsdc
being heavily involved in armor Wars now
that they have so much Stark Tech we
could definitely see him or many of him
I'm gonna check you right there for a
second John sword created the white
Vision you're right you're right
I apologize and the way I see it there
are two separate entities they're the
FBI and the CIA right swords out there
I'm Gonna Leave swords uh Cosmic uh
dodc's domestic right yeah
terrestrial and domestic I'm sure uh uh
gogc would love to get their hands on
this white Vision especially after their
they took all that Stark Tech maybe
they'll claim uh ownership here's how I
get back here it's intellectual property
of the stuff that They seized or
something who knows who who owns white
Vision that's a good question who owns
white Vision he was the casket that was
being made the form for Ultron was being
made in that uh South Korean facility
but was that like a tone was that a
stark project thing or was that a
totally separate was that woman that
doctor I forget
yeah was she working four times for Tony
Stark was that like a Tony Stark
International thing gosh we gotta go
back when Vision was first
created because this is just the the
metal but then Thor oh because they
steal it and then that's right so I
think it was yeah Ultron was making her
do it I'm pretty sure yeah Ultron just
like went into that facility this is a
separate facilities whatever this
company is giving back to Ultron is I
guess here's what I say yeah maybe
Justin Hammer owns uh Whitefish and he
can make claim to it return I don't know
where Justin Hammer alive in the MCU
he was in the prison
the guys showed up in all hail the king
yeah very ominous with the gun yeah the
ten Rings was looking for it 10 Rings
we're looking for him so yeah he'll be
back he'll be back they'll break traffic
coming back
white vision of black panther yeah yeah
no that's the one taking on Williams
that was Helen Cho's own personal lab oh
good for her so her own personal app so
she has ownership over White Bridge yeah
return well has Helen Show dead or is
she just not in good shape clearly we
haven't seen the Age of Ultron
are we completing idiots or just barely
so in that same weirdo in the YouTube
comments goes oh it's the poser crew
again today's today's
right today sorry we didn't just watch
Age of Ultron 2 or Age of Ultron right
before that yeah so about this
Thunderbolts movie which will definitely
have white vision bucket yeah uh when do
we think that's going to take place it's
the end of phase five is it the last
movie of phase five it is the last movie
yeah and then the first is was Fantastic
Four right six right right okay you know
sometimes they do a weird movie at the
end of a phase right like phase three
ended with Far From Home phase two ended
with Ant-Man yeah I think you're right
um not always Avengers movies although
it feels like The Avengers movies are
sort of the capstones for those phases
so I don't think they're beholden to
making this like the big Team Up movie
to end Facebook I think it could be more
of an irreverent separate thing like
kind of the way Suicide Squad it kind of
exists outside of the DC EU except for
the I mean the first one Batman was in
it but like I think that you kind of can
have this Thunderbolts movie might be a
like side tangential project that
creates this new team that's available
for things but doesn't necessarily
dialed directly into the the can gang
Saga or whatever we're headed into it's
a separate Adventure yes do you think
the Thunderbolts are gonna be like
suicide squad where they are our heroes
or are they going to be more villainous
well if are they gonna happen if they
fight or are they the villains of this
movie do they have the guns to make the
Thunderbolts the villains you can't do
the title being the Thunderbolts and and
make them the villains why not right
because who are the heroes who are we
following I thought There Will Be Blood
that follows the villain that whole
thing yeah but I mean to say like he's
still the protagonist right they can be
the protagonist but they're the villain
Paul Paul uh Dano also a villain in that
movie even though right you know so I
would say like there's not going to be a
good guy in the Thunderbolts that they
are fighting because they're not gonna
fight like The Avengers no they would
have called this like the Young Avengers
movie or Young Avengers versus
Thunderbolts I don't think they're gonna
do a versus in a title because I mean
having the Thunderbolts fight a bunch of
teenagers would be very weird flex but
they're pretty young right John Walker
that we're expecting right John Walker
Elena don't compare to like Kate bishop
and oh yeah Tommy and wicked running
around yeah Tommy yeah yeah
um yeah that's a good point I think I
think the villain will I think Tommy's
nailed it I think the villain will just
be like a villain like some aliens from
space or some demons Santa Claus Santa
Claus are they gonna kill some innocent
civilians in the process absolutely John
Walker's already done it yeah yeah he
killed and innocent sub billion yeah um
what was the stone not stonecutter
that's from The Simpsons the Stone
Cutters
with the shield yeah we killed that one
yeah I guess not that innocent I want to
see some innocent people die okay that's
my mind all right that's my marble oh
it's my favorite time of day when the
spam sex spammers future is here dating
match 84 84. who's that for which one of
them
uh hey we got a new tattoo to wrap up
the show today thank you guys thank you
so much let's actually go through some
of these super chats Mr Mr Krabs being
wild in the chat today he said he said
I'm back anyone missed me and then he
said can I get a oh yeah
sending in a hot take what kind of
forever teaser is the best movie in
Facebook the teaser's the best movie
that's a little I love some chunky baby
um
uh Mike Noki sent in a Super Chat my
long shot is that Jen represents Frank
Castle guys do two tattoos two random
picks uh my long shot is that Jen
represents Frank Castle he was with Matt
uh but his war crimes quote unquote got
okay Scott moved up to the Superhuman
law which brings Daredevil in uh
possible oh that's where PJ masks oh
more PJ masks I got Mario with a show
Adam Ramirez saying vanillavision back
in Thunderbolts
tomorrow because if so so hyped yeah
he's a rapping vision
uh what is love persevering
I wear very shiny earrings sorry Santa
uh Tibetan Mastiff sending a Super Chat
can we talk about how overpowered the
Marvel zombies are versus the heroes the
heroes then zero chance
um here's the deal if you do any sort of
like Zombie Thing the zombies have to be
super powerful it's not fun if the
zombies aren't more powerful I agree yes
the zombies are driven by more pure
Instinct and less care for themselves oh
that's a good PJ that looks great I
can't even see if the camera's in the
way postie uh
I have people coming over tonight
well I hope they like your channel
I got a Mario and I got spin from Frozen
oh I got a flash that's problematic oh I
got uh
well as long as the Flash doesn't go
into someone in a grocery store I think
you're yeah I have never
you guys think happened to the babies of
pregnant women that were snapped Away by
Thanos definitely mutants am I right
we've long theorized on this channel
that the snap definitely did something
really got into people's jeans and
messed them up now speaking of getting
into jeans where's that dating app again
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
um I don't think uh I don't I think
they'll explain mutants differently
right Amman is or not Iman hi I'm on
um is is too old to have been like a
baby yeah
I think if anything to snap the energy
it puts out did more than anything it
didn't have is that whether you were
snapped away or not it was just like the
energy in the atmosphere right sure
right the radius maybe it activated some
sort of you know mutant gene or whatever
it is but yeah yeah I don't know I mean
those babies probably have like cancer
oh well that's a great thing then to
show on
how about we go to Rogue bricks when
will we see the Punisher again at your
mom's house
Lewisberry said it in a super chat I
hope to get in Thunderbolts Frank and
Poindexter it's Frank Frank Castle who's
join Dexter Texas
what a bunch of posers on the show today
but we hope you had a wonderful Thursday
here comic
a stand-up comic uh hey what's the deal
with champagne O'Connor oh
take that Pope Green Jacket you know
what I always rip off the pictures hey
we're still doing our clip of the weeks
on our Discord if you're 18 years or
older be sure to head on over to our
Discord you can submit your favorite
break room clip in our Discord uh and
we're gonna start showing those at the
end of the week you can also submit
voicemails in our Discord we've got a
question call me for any of these posers
up here uh send it in it could be a
question about the movies a question
about anything else the question about
our lives now I've got permanently got
the flash on my arm wow you and me both
brother oh yeah
most of the people he hangs out with
right they end up with some sort of
permanent mark from the place
we worked so hard to not talk about
something CW flash
I meant Grant Gustin falls on Tic Tac
we're at the underscore break room Ross
on Instagram also at the underscore
break room yeah yeah no no and I think
it's NR underscore break room no no
the whole time was Comic-Con
set your clocks wake up early don't
sleep don't sleep at all stay awake tell
your friends and family they gotta be
the photomicon especially if they've
never watched the show they'll love it
even more
said references
and Susan delucci okay let's get her the
Emmy folks thank you so much for joining
us today we hope you have a wonderful
evening we'll see you next time Breakers
adios
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]